merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Ie
Abou merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre non les policiers brois tout
comme les autres d'ailleurs ne récl pas
plus d'argent ils veulent juste être
respectés après l'attaque lâche de qure
policiers le 8 octobre à V Chatillon
brûlant gravement deux d'entre eu c'est
toutes la France républicaine qui a été
profondément choquée et meurtrie et
d'ailleurs à Lyon à Dijon nos policiers
ont subi pratiquement le même sort
jusqu'à présent la France souffrait
doutait mais les Français sen remettz
traditionnellement à la solidité de nos
forces de l'ordre or les Français
découvrent avec peine que les policiers
n'ont pas suffisamment de moyens pour
remplir leur mission depuis maintenant
plusieurs semaines ces derniers défilent
et interpelle les pouvoirs publics à ce
sujet ce weekend pas plus de 500
policiers et citoyens se sont rassemblés
devant le commissariat de béziier et sur
fond de marseillaise ils ont ensemble
réclamé le respect monsieur le ministre
quand la République est attaquée il faut
lui donner les moyens de se défendre et
je voudrais dire ici et certainement au
nom de beaucoup de mes collègues ici et
en face à nos policiers à nos gendarmes
tout notre respect toute notre
reconnaissance
abisier par exemple les policiers
manquent de tout monsieur le ministre
véhicule ancien matériel obsolè
locovetust et particulièrement inadapté
à leur nouvelle mission à TR à TR dans
un bureau pour interroger une victime ou
un malfaiteur c'est juste inadmissible
on le sait vous le savez le commissariat
est quasi insalubre vous en avez promis
l'extension d'ici à fin 2016 il nous
reste quelques semaines monsieur le
ministre à baisier comme ailleurs
qu'allez-vous faire pour notre police
merci merci la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard casenu ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le député Abou
merci pour votre question concernant la
situation de la police nationale de la
gendarmerie et je souhaite que l'on
puisse aborder cette question comme
l'ensemble des questions qui touchent à
la sécurité avec la volonté de rassurer
et de donner des gages à ceux qui sont
en première ligne pour assurer la
sécurité des Français dans un esprit qui
soit le plus rigoureux possible si la
situation est ce que vous décrivez c'est
parce que depuis de nombreuses années de
très nombreuses années il n'y a pas eu
suffisamment d'investissement sur
l'immobilier des forces de police sur le
matériel et que beaucoup de questions
sont restées en suspens qu'est-ce que
nous faisons concrètement d'abord pour
ce qui concerne les questions qui
touchent au respect les questions qui
touchent aux moyens de la police
nationale je veux parler des moyens
juridiques nous avons pris des
engagements et nous les tiendrons d'ici
à la fin du mois de novembre des
dispositions législatives seront
présentées concernant la légitime
défense il y a actuellement un groupe de
travail qui se réunit et qui permettra
d'aller au bout de ce que nous avons
déjà engagé puisque je rappelle que nous
avons nous modifié le régime de la
légitime défense en juin qu'il y a des
compléments qui sont demandés et nous en
tenons compte deux sur l'anonymisation
qui est la garantie que les forces de
l'ordre pour vont être protégé
lorsqu'elles interviennent dans des
quartiers sensibles et sur l'outrage à
force de l'ordre qui sera aligné sur
l'outrage à magistrat il faut bien
entendu réhausser les moyens nous avons
augmenté de 15 % les crédits
d'investissement pour la police et la
gendarmerie c'est ce qui a permis par
exemple l'an dernier de livrer 7000
véhicules dans la police et les
gendarmeries et je souhaite que nous
puissions en urgence cont tenu d'une
violence qui monte donner à la police et
à la gendarmerie les moyens de compléter
les matériels dont ils ont besoin et
c'est la raison pour pour laquelle nous
avons mis en place ce plan de 250
millions d'euros j'irai réceptionner les
premiers matériels à crille dans
quelques jours et je préciserai le
calendrier précis de livraison à la
sécurité publique de l'ensemble des
matériels dont celle-ci a besoin